alright I'm excited it is Christmastime
this is one of the it's what the hell
was that what is that noise oh it's my
cappuccino machine I'm sorry it's my
first time using it okay I'm sorry
why do you have a cappuccino machine oh
I came here straight from Ellen she's
doing her 12 Days of Giveaways now I
can't wait to see what you're gonna give
me I hope that it's not a cappuccino
machine okay let me explain Ellen is on
the same lot as yeah she's like two
stages away she gives away a lot of
Christmas gifts to her audience so Ellen
also got me an iPhone 9 it comes
pre-programmed with Ellen's home phone
number ow that's great
that's great okay what are you doing now
Ellen gave me a pair of jon Hamm's used
basketballs Wow okay don't snip those
also got each of us this amazing
terracotta statue of a warrior from the
Chinese emperor Kim Chi Yong's
army okay I seriously doubt that's
authentic it couldn't be it well I can
test it and my brand-new
MRI machine
[Music]
[Applause]
do you even know how to use an MRI
machine I don't have to know because
Ellen gave each of us our own person
personal Fabio to operate it
[Applause]
[Music]
fabien should not be operating an MRI
machine
let him I'm really sorry ma'am I don't
give presents to the studio audience
well then why are they here they're here
to enjoy the show
look I'm serious we don't have any gifts
for you hello Ellen this cheap prick
doesn't do Christmas can you back up my
space shuttle
you
you